you kind of
like a lot of these stories are
surprising right like because you you
kind of led with you know slow athletic
white guy cappuccino
you're knocking these dudes out you're
winning the golden glove thing and your
dad's surprised like were you just
faster stronger mentally tougher what
was your but again
i think i think because of the my
perspective
our definition of athletic is completely
different yes
there's levels to the game there's
there's levels for sure it's like you
know i had a rich friend growing up
compared to the
rich friend i have
that guy's [ __ ] dirt but like there's
levels to everything so no question so i
think like i'm not kane velasquez so to
me like
now that i'm older and have success in
comedy and podcasting i can look back at
it and go damn at least getting a sean
it feels pretty good man getting to the
ufc being ranked in the top 10 in the
world pretty good dude but at the time
as a failure i felt like a
loser man let me ask you it took years
to get over that but stay different
usually i wouldn't even talk about like
usually i wouldn't even talk about
fighting i usually step this is recent
for me like probably in the last year
i've started talking more about fighting
usually i don't talk about why why is
that i don't know emotional or is it
like yeah i don't know i don't know but
but because i want to be taken so
serious as a comic yeah
like my manager like no fighting
questions
let me ask you did you get into fighting
i know you say you just get stay in the
shape because my dude i was i was joking
with that my story is eerily similar to
yours you're just way better at it at
every step of the level than me i was
like i'm [ __ ] great value brendon
schaub this sucks dude but the your
knockoff brown i'm walmart
and schmelz over here but the
so i got into mma after baseball didn't
work out because i had nothing i had to
go all the whole time i was playing ball
all i wanted to do was make money i was
like dude i've i fell out of love with
the game and i'm like if i just made
money i'd be the happiest guy in the
world my girl left me not making any
money traveling the course of the world
my father's saying the same thing i get
a contract to go play in korea and i'm
like this is my big break dad i'm going
to korea going to play ball for 60 grand
like tom selleck and mr b yeah i know
that's sad my dad broke it down the
mustang dad broke it down he was like i
just want you to understand you're 25
your big break is to make 60 grand in
the third world country and you're still
doing this god damn it yeah all right so
i'm out and now you know two years later
i'm doing pharmaceutical sales like
every other drop out making more money
ever thought i'd make in my life that
suicidal i hated everything about my
life got into jiu jitsu all this other
stuff was good at it started fighting
but at the whole time i was doing that
all i was doing was chasing the failure
yeah all i was doing was was chasing
that failure you had to stick with you
and i'm wondering like with you with
football and everything like that you
put everything in your life you walk on
you could have quit at any point you
kept rising to the challenge rising the
challenge at that point were you like i
i still haven't reached the mountaintop
i got to find a new mountain i got i got
to prove to myself yeah i don't know
it's a mountaintop but i i think a lot
of things like in office you've uh
accomplished this it's like a lot of
people
if they get labeled as a fighter or a
football player like that sticks with
them that that stuff i never care about
like the labels like even back then no i
never viewed myself as just a football
player just a fighter just a comic ever
and then i've also never ever ever in my
life done anything for money nothing
stand up podcasting nothing's ever for
money
if it's if it's good and the content's
out there hopefully the money comes if
not i'm i i love doing it you'll go with
it good with it got it like my shows in
florida they could but i should be
paying them i don't care
i mean i'm glad that don't tell the
bookers that because you're having that
much fun don't tell them you're having
not much fun
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]